and again my next guest has written to
the scottish government after strict
quarantine rules kept her from spending
time with her extremely ill father
at the queen elizabeth university
hospital in glasgow
claire herriot arrived in edinburgh from
istanbul on tuesday night and was
granted a one-off
compassionate visit to see her dad she
was escorted from a hotel room by two
guards who then returned her
to her room after the very short visit
she'd answers now
from her quarantine in edinburgh hello
to you thanks for joining us um this
morning
tell us what's happened
yes well i saw my dad um
the other day for a quarantine visit
i've been
uh granted two more but
to get to this point it's been
incredibly difficult
and unnecessarily stressful um
protected exchanges of email to get this
far
and i think if this was an option if i
if i could have these visits why
why make it so difficult in the first
place but now what my issue is what i'm
trying to convey what i wrote in my
email is that
i now have a concern about my own health
and well-being
in this facility and i'm not getting
anywhere when i try and say that
i'm trying to explain that in the
in the document in my hotel it says that
you can
request an assessment by a medical
professional in the
on the premises i've tried that person's
not here and it's just very frustrating
to
to get that to get that attention
what are you being told by the
authorities why are you being kept there
well they they you know they say that um
these are the quarantine measures that
are that are in place
and it's you know for the
protection of of everyone but what i'm
what i'm trying to say is
that it's quite it's quite difficult to
understand it's quite difficult to
accept when
the country is opening back up when
thousands of football fans
travel from scotland to london when
there's nightclubs open in london
and it seems to me that the the prime
minister's policies just let it rip
but i'm being locked away like a
biohazard
when it doesn't need to be this way i'm
saying that
i have a mental health concern i've
raised that i spoke to my
doctor on the recommendation of an email
i received from the
scottish managed isolation team i then
forwarded them the doctor's letter
yesterday at 3pm
and they haven't replied and that's the
kind of thing i'm talking about what i'm
saying is
i i called 1-1-1 they they were
very kind and compassionate and they
advised that i call the covert helpline
i call the covet helpline
and they told me to call 1-1-1 how how
does a person get
get any kind of assessment about their
own mental health their own well-being
in one of these
facilities that's what i'm really really
struggling with
how's your dad
yeah he um is comfortable and the
hospital in glasgow
are doing a wonderful job for them my my
mum
told the consultant that he is the best
of
the nhs my dad was very confused about
why i had to leave the other day
and that was heartbreaking and when i
when i got back from that
visit i was very distressed and that is
when i
tried to get the assessment by the
medical professional that it says in
this document
in my room that's when i called 1-1-1
that's when i
tried to to reach out and say what are
you doing for the people
not just me the people in these
facilities that need to access some kind
of support
and that's been very difficult
and i'm really really struggling with
that and my big fear now
is that i'll be stuck in this hotel when
i'm unable to leave
if my if my father dies before the 7th
of august when this quarantine
is up and so i am grateful for
the visits i don't understand why i had
to go through what i had to go through
to get them if that mechanism existed in
the first place
but what i'm asking now what i'm saying
is that i
i i believe that the threshold that's
been explained in this document to me
about being able to be assessed your own
mental health to leave this facility
i'm not getting i'm i've so far that's
not been listened to it's very
frustrating
to to make these points to be told to
speak to your gp to then talk to your gp
she writes a letter which i then forward
and i don't get a reply for the email
that i sent at three o'clock yesterday
and that's what i don't understand what
is this how people are being treated in
21st century scotland when they try
and get help for their for their own
mental health in one of these
quarantine facilities i i know i'm not
the only person
and this is this is what i don't
understand
i don't understand where the where the
compassion has gone what do you want to
say to nicolas sturgeon
well to you know to the first minister
to the
the scottish government in general i
understand that
governments have to balance the welfare
of millions of people
against the needs of individuals and
families
but i think we're at the point now where
the emergency measures stage
has has passed and cases should be
judged on their
individual merits why are people having
to go through
these protracted exchanges of email
to get the thing that they should have
had in the first place i think that
there's a lot of additional
unnecessary suffering there's already
people are suffering to begin with
because of the pandemic situation
and there's not there's not enough uh
help and enough consideration to
minimize the suffering that there's
already going to be it's obviously hard
for anyone
who is facing the prospect of losing a
very close
relative what i'm saying is why does it
have to be made
so much harder i don't think there's
enough
uh for in my experience enough health
for people in these facilities who are
trying to reach out for
mental health concerns if somebody in
one of these hotels falls and breaks
their arm
they're going to get attention i'm now
saying i'm the canadian the coal mine
that if this
if this situation gets worse i am going
to struggle to cope with that i'm
telling you that now
and i don't even get response to the
email
that that is what i just i think is is
so lacking
and it's unnecessary it doesn't have to
be this way
claire um all your colleagues former
colleagues here at sky news are rooting
for you
um look after yourself my love stay
strong
and i'm sure that you'll be able to see
your father before too long hopefully
the scottish government listening this
morning
and we'll be able to help you be brave
here
thank you thank you
we asked for a comment from the scottish
government last night none has been
forthcoming